We tend to think that the world is organized
around a small group of enormous superpowers
that pull the strings of everything. The United
States, China, the United Kingdom, maybe until
recently Russia, maybe in the future, India...
But what if I told you that there are much
smaller, seemingly insignificant
countries that suddenly achieve
gigantic influence on a global scale?
What if we were to talk about countries that
are neither the richest in the world, nor do they
necessarily have nuclear weapons, large armies
or a large population, but have nevertheless
managed to carve out a niche for themselves on
the international geopolitical chessboard?
Well, VisualPolitik viewers, in this video
we are going to give you several examples of
countries that, despite being relatively small,
are breaking all the molds.
But first it would not be out
of place to shine a light on the ultimate key to
its renewed influence: we are talking about what
is known as soft power. And, take note, this can
be much more important than you might imagine.
We could say that this type of strategy
or power consists of being able to impact,
influence and persuade people around the
world to achieve certain objectives. In
order to do this, elements such as
culture, values, innovation, sports,
diplomacy and even philanthropy are used.
It is the opposite concept to hard power,
which is exercised through coercion, the use
of force or threats and economic blackmail. A
type of power in which, not surprisingly,
the great powers have many advantages.
In other words, in summary, while
hard power depends on force, soft
power depends on persuasion and attraction.
Let's see, as far as influence and military
presence go, we have already talked about them
in a lot of videos. It is a recurring theme on
VisualPolitik. However, what we have rarely talked
about is how any country can expand its relevance
and international influence by resorting to
persuasion. This can also be a real lifeline
for the country’s companies and products.
And, believe me, it’s no joke. Many countries
are already developing this line of work.
So, without further ado...Shall we find out which
countries are able to compete head-to-head with
the major powers? How exactly are they doing it?
Well, VisualPolitik viewers, we are
going to look at every aspect of
this new approach. And do you know what? We are
going to illustrate it with concrete examples.
Let's get started.
T1(THE EMERGENCE OF 'K-POWER')
One of the countries that has most
increased its international influence
and improved its external image in recent
times is... Yes, indeed, South Korea.
Here on VisualPolitik we have already talked
about this country in several videos. We have
talked about political, economic, military and
even social issues, but what we have never talked
about is how this country has become one of
the most popular countries in the world...
I'm sure you’ve all heard about KPOP or Korean
series that have taken Netflix by storm,
such as, for example, The Squid Game.
But long before all that, before Gangnam
Style became the most watched video on YouTube,
before groups like BTS and Black Pink conquered
the world, and before the movie Parasite
won four Oscars, the so-called "Korean
wave" had already conquered the Asian continent.
Maybe even some of you, as a result of all this,
have been encouraged to try
Korean food..... A cuisine
that is also becoming more and more popular.
Cinema, music, culture and gastronomy... It
may not seem much to us, but isn't it surprising
that a country like this is having such a global
impact? Have you ever thought, for example, about
the cars that systematically appear in Korean TV
series? If you haven't, take a look, but they are
almost always either Hyundai, Genesis or Kia.
We could almost talk about a mega ad for one of
this country’s most important industries. And,
of course, we're not just talking about
cars. But that's just one aspect of
this huge global exhibition.
It’s a kind of exposure that,
in the case of South Korea, has not come out
of nowhere. Quite the contrary. We could go
so far as to say that it has been part of
a State strategy for several decades now.
You see, many experts believe that government
support was key in the Hallyu, the Korean wave
of cultural content that emerged in the 1990s.
For example, in 1998, then President Kim
Dae-jung [PRON: Kim Day Tsong] announced the first
plan to support the Hallyu industry. The aim was
to boost the cultural industry to make it a great
showcase for the country. And it was not just hot
air. In just three years, the public budget
allocated to the cultural industry tripled.
The success was so resounding that the
next government, that of Roh Moo-hyun,
continued to increase investment in the
cultural industry. In fact, several laws were
also established as well as government agencies
aimed exclusively at promoting this cultural
content both inside and outside the country.
Let's see, yes, I know what you're thinking...
If it were as easy as putting money on the
table, many countries could do the same, right?
Yes, you are absolutely right. In fact
the truth is that in this case, the key
to the success of the Korean wave was not really
the economic contribution of the government,
but above all that the process was totally
directed and managed by private companies and
production companies focused on making profits.
Let's just say that in this case the government
played a role similar to that of the State of
Israel in the promotion of technology companies,
as we recently told you on VisualEconomik. That
is, it put up the money to support the industry,
but gave it all the control... With
a very clear premise: they had to be
competitive on their own. That is, they
had to make as much money as possible.
And so, little by little, the State was
nurturing a sector that could bring them a
lot of international visibility. Take a look.
C1("Culture has surfaced as an indispensable
element of a nation's competitiveness and economic
resource that produces added value. To keep in
pace with this changing global environment,
Korea has adopted cultural diplomacy as a
new pillar of the country's diplomatic make
up" – 2010 Diplomatic White Paper of Korea)
And believe me when I tell you that they
take it quite seriously. For example,
the South Korean Ministry of Foreign Affairs
conducts research on the impact of Hallyu
in each country, and based on the results,
promotes fan activities and cultural events.
Another example is that the government
is sponsoring 20 to 30 percent of a
huge $1 billion investment fund
aimed at growing and exporting
Korean pop culture. As you can see,
this has not come about by chance.
So the question is, what for? Well, one of the
objectives of this strong commitment has been
to improve South Korea's international image. A
country that since its foundation in 1948 went
through a devastating war and a succession
of military dictatorships until the 1990s.
Dictatorships that, obviously, consistently
violated human rights and contributed to the
country's rather negative image abroad.
For a long time, South Korea was seen as
a kind of mega-factory run by satraps and
huge family business conglomerates that were
supported by corrupt politicians. As you can
imagine, that was not the best calling card.
So when democracy arrived in the country
known as the Land of Morning Calm,
politicians not only had to get down
to work to clean up the institutions,
but they also had to work hard to improve
the country's image at home and abroad.
And there you have it...
No sooner said than done!
But do you know what? There are a couple
of facts that can help us understand the
enormous success they have had.
For example, according to the
World Tourism Organization, between 1995 and
2019, which is the latest pre-pandemic data,
the number of tourists received by South Korea
grew by 367 percent, from about 3.75 million to
almost 18 million. Thus tourism is becoming
a huge and entirely new source of income.
Another fact that demonstrates the influence
that this cultural commitment has had is the
number of people who suddenly decide
to study their language. We can look,
for example, at the number of students who
sign up for official exams every year.
Well, take note, the number of TOPIK
applicants has increased by almost 14,000
percent between 1997 and 2019. In 2019
there were some 400,000 applicants,
almost four times more than those who signed up,
for example, for the official DELE Spanish exams.
And let's not forget that Korean
is a minority language globally,
with just 80 million native speakers,
making those figures a real milestone.
As a comparison, it should be noted that
Spain spends 170 million euros every year
on the Cervantes Institute – basically on its
head office, branches and public employees.
An institution whose essential function
is to promote Spanish around the world.
Well, what can I say? With the data
in hand... South Korea's commitment to
private enterprise and competitive content
has clearly been much more successful.
Especially if we also take into account
that the Spanish language has the second
highest number of native speakers and is
much, much more influential in the world.
But let's not get sidetracked.
The fact is that all this impact obviously
translates into a huge extra source of revenue
for the South Korean economy. And that’s not all.
It is also a way to promote South Korea's
political image to the rest of the world,
which, in addition to increasing trade, diplomatic
and political exchanges, could be particularly
important in the event of a conflict, for example,
with North Korea. It is clear that the things we
know and value matter much more to us.
It is a strategy that countries like
Israel are now also following. Have
you noticed that there is more and
more Israeli content on streaming platforms?
Well, take note, because its implications
are more important than we might think.
Take a look, for example, at this news item:
N1(Fauda's Season 4 breaks viewership
records in the Middle East. i24news)
N2(Netflix's controversial show 'Fauda'
tops Arab countries watchlist. The News)
Fauda is a series focused on the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict. A Hebrew-produced
series that is now helping to change the
image of this conflict in Arab countries.
It is an incredibly powerful loudspeaker.
Of course, the use of culture is just one
example... But it is far from the only
way to achieve similar objectives...
There are other possible strategies that can turn
a remote and/or relatively small country in terms
of population into an influential global power.
Do you want to know more? Then stay tuned.
T2(THE POWER OF THE WALLET)
Apart from movies, TV series and music,
which are undoubtedly excellent tools
for improving a country's image, the
truth is that there is still a lot more.
A very clear example is the case of Qatar.
And no, don't worry because we are not going
to talk about the Qatar World Cup again,
although the truth is that this event had a
lot to do with everything we are talking about.
An example of a huge political marketing
campaign... And an economic one.
However, there is still something
more important than that.
You see, as many of you probably already know,
Qatar is one of the largest hydrocarbon exporters
in the world. It specializes mainly in
the export of liquefied natural gas,
which has made it one of the
richest countries on the planet.
Qatar has money galore... And do you know what?
There's a way to use that stash of cash to not
only get profitability... but also influence.
As we have already told you in the past,
this emirate of the Persian Gulf invests a
large part of the profits from hydrocarbon
exploitation through a sovereign fund
called the Qatar Investment Authority.
This fund has more than $450 billion in assets,
which amounts to more than $150,000 per resident
and more than $1 million per Qatari national.
Well, the bulk of all this money, some $400
billion, is invested in 80 different countries,
with the United Kingdom having the largest number
of Qatari investments with some $40 billion.
For example, the Qataris own some $12 billion
in real estate properties throughout the UK. In
addition, this fund is also the largest owner
of real estate in London, while it also has
significant investments in bricks and mortar
in cities such as Paris and Washington DC.
And the truth is that the list could go on
ad infinitum. But of course, we're not
just talking about buildings. We are
talking above all about strategic bets:
For example, Qatar's claws also reach into
the realm of critical infrastructure. The country
has been buying all or part of ports and liquefied
natural gas terminals in the rest of the world.
And it also has stakes in a lot of multinationals.
For instance, they are one of the largest
shareholders of the Volkswagen Group.
Evidently the control of these pieces of
infrastructure and its presence in the
shareholding of many large companies
gives the Qatari government enormous
influence over the entire planet.
But wait a minute, because that's
not the end of it. Qatari money also
has other, more "alternative" uses.
In their quest for political and social influence,
they have invested heavily in the world of sports.
Without going any further, and I'm sure you all
know this, Qatar owns Paris Saint Germain football
club. It is their flagship. And now they want
to take control of Manchester United as well.
Likewise, the Arab world's leading television
network, Al Jazeera, is also Qatari.
In other words, Qatar is leveraging oil and gas
money to seek not only profitability but also
political and economic influence.
Controlling huge media outlets,
major soccer clubs, critical infrastructure and
large shareholdings in some of the world's most
important multinationals, the Qataris are always
welcomed through the front door despite being
a country of just 2.7 million inhabitants,
of which just over 300,000 are nationals.
It is an extraordinary use of money to achieve
not only profitability but also soft power... Doha
has become one of the great political capitals of
the Arab world and the checkbook has played a key
role. Without going any further, Qatari money has
also served to boost its brotherhood with Turkey.
And yes, it is true that Qatar has also
developed many actions of a strictly
political nature, such as supporting the
Muslim Brothers, or of a military nature,
such as giving the United States the
largest military base in the Middle East,
but the truth is that the checkbook has played a
key role in making Doha much more important and
influential than, for example, Kuwait,
a potentially even wealthier country.
Let's just say that taking advantage of
available resources to gain influence is
another key to soft power. It may seem obvious to
you, but the truth is that it is not so common.
But, before ending this video, we cannot overlook
a third way that relatively small countries have
at their disposal to become great political powers
in addition to the use of culture and money.
Do you know what we are referring to?
Well... Listen up.
T3 (KINGS OF HEARTS)
Another way to compete with the most powerful
powers in the world is to become a standard
bearer for just causes and political projects.
To tell you about this, we are going to give you
two very different examples: Canada and Cuba.
We are talking about two countries that play in
totally different geopolitical spheres, but that
have managed to exploit their strengths to achieve
regional and even international relevance.
Now, the question is... how did they do it? Well,
in the case of Canada, what they did was
to become a standard bearer for civil
liberties and environmental protection.
For example, Canada has been one of the
countries that has taken the UN declaration on
the rights of indigenous peoples most seriously.
And yes, I know what you're thinking... this
all sounds lovely, but can you really achieve
international influence with these things?
Well, the truth is, yes. This can be one of
the key tools for achieving it and
Canada is a clear example of this.
This North American country has
been one of the major promoters
of important international treaties.
For example, there is the Ottawa Treaty,
signed in 1997, which seeks
to ban anti-personnel mines.
Or the 1987 Montreal Protocol, which
sets guidelines for reducing the use
of chlorofluorocarbons in order
to protect the ozone layer.
And many of you may find all these things
irrelevant, but the truth is that they all
contribute to building a country's brand and
increasing its international influence. Think
of it this way, everyone wants to be close to
the most popular person in the class. And this
is something that affects governments, companies,
investments, products and professionals. It is,
in a way, the marketing campaign of
a lifetime applied to countries.
But what about Cuba? Why have we included
such an impoverished country in this
video if it is a communist dictatorship?
Well, although it may seem contradictory,
that is precisely the point. A country as poor
as Cuba, which has neither money, nor significant
companies, nor a modern army, nor practically
anything else, has managed to become one of the
most influential countries in the Americas.
How did it achieve this? Well, by resorting
to political strategies. In a past video here
on VisualPolitik we saw how they used doctors.
That would be one example. But Cuba goes much
further, and if it stands out for anything it
has been precisely for making intense use of the
populist strategy that we could summarize as:
"the subjugated countries versus
the United States and Europe which
are great imperialist and exploiting powers."
This discourse has been bought and bought a lot in
many Latin American countries such as Venezuela,
where the Cubans first managed to establish a
puppet dictatorship through Hugo Chavez.
Then, with Venezuela's own oil money,
they were able to finance their own revolution
throughout the rest of Latin America.
The idea seems brilliant...
Maybe evil, but brilliant.
Throughout the continent, Cuba
has promoted political parties,
social pressure groups and even institutional
forums such as the well-known Sao Paulo Forum.
Spaces from which politicians such
as Rafael Correa, Evo Morales,
Daniel Ortega and Manuel Celaya emerged.
The idea on which the Cuban influence in
Latin America was built was quite pragmatic. The
Castro regime realized that the left would not
succeed in Latin America if it did not shed – at
least in the face of the gallery – the old dogmas.
Dogmas such as ending private
property or establishing proletarian
dictatorships.
Beyond the purely
ideological question, what interest could
Cuba have in exporting its revolution?
Well, for many analysts, its primary
objective would be precisely to guarantee
the very existence of the Cuban regime.
With the demise of the Soviet Union in the
early 1990s and the severe economic and social
crisis this caused in the Caribbean country,
the Castros realized that they needed
an international support network.
A network that had to be in Latin America,
countries that are close to each other,
speak the same language and have
more or less the same culture.
And do you know what? It turned out well,
and news stories like this one are just proof
of how a small, backward and poor country
achieved enormous international influence.
N3((50% of the gasoline produced
by Venezuela is sent to Cuba,
a union leader from that country says
"Only 10% of the gasoline that is being produced
reaches the population". – Diario de Cuba)
Anyway, as you can see, there are many
ways to achieve international influence
despite being a relatively small country.
From South Korea's cultural content to Cuba's
revolutionary policy, from Qatar's macro economic
investments to Canada's philanthropy.
What is clear is that if you can develop
some creativity with a good global vision,
virtually any country can become a major
power in geopolitical influence.
And make no doubt about it,
all the countries we have seen in this video
have reaped great benefits with this type of
strategy. So it's no trivial matter.
But now, at this point it is your turn:
do you think that your country could follow the
example of one of these countries to have more
international presence? Do you think that this
kind of power of attraction is lasting over time?
Leave us your comment below. And
remember, if you liked this video
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our channel so you don't miss any news.
Once again, thank you very much for being
there. All the best and see you next time.